la lettre au mali de tout stress
nationale se sont rendus dans une
entreprise qui propose figurez-vous à
ses employés de choisir eux mêmes quand
ils veulent prendre leurs vacances et de
façon illimitée
on va regarder l'extrait qui vont me
dire est que vous emporte ning
aujourd'hui le bureau de dorothée
cargèse qui est inoccupée cette
responsable d'agencé a décidé de rester
chez elles comme la majorité des
salariés en france et là cinq semaines
de congés neuf jours de rtt mais
particularité de son entreprise
elle peut en rajouter autant qu'elles le
souhaitent pour pouvoir prendre ses
congés il faut d'abord atteindre des
objectifs chiffrés pour l'entreprise
c'est un outil pour recruter et motiver
les troupes
c'est une manière de les impliquer de
les responsabiliser
puisque comme on leur donne un avantage
très précieux en contrepartie
s'investissent beaucoup dans leur
travail
alors c'est pour les motiver les
responsabiliser j'ai l'impression qu'on
parle quand même d'enfants à la crèche
un pardon mais me direz ce que vous en
pensez
et est-ce que par ailleurs c'est cette
motivation c'est pas surtout une
pression pour se dire vite vite vite si
je terminais que ces jeunes j'ai atteint
mes objectifs de pouvoir partir en
vacances comme je veux quand je veux
je vois thibault qui fait non de la tête
a dû tout faire et tout plus de repos
plus de forces vives plus de
productivité plus d'argent le nouveau
monde ski sourire ça d'accord retrouver
sa forme il alors j'adore vos tisanes
objectif vous dites moi j'ai les lancent
ils à leurs parents la raison des
révélations autonomie liberté en europe
jusqu'à n'a pas l'air d'accord je suis
totalement contre
parce que moi je suis honnête évidemment
comme quand on dit vieux je n'avais des
vacances illimitée à partir du moment où
vous remplissez vos objectifs
je vais me dépêcher de remplir mes
objectifs et hop salut la compagnie non
mais c'était pour l'entreprise parce que
lenovo c'est ce qu'on appelle win-win
dans la berme marketing c'est à dire
tout le monde est gagnant
vous partez en vacances l'entreprise a
les objectifs remplis nancement moi ce
que je pense c'est que quand tu restes
dans son entreprise une fois que tu as
rempli ses objectifs du coup tu es là
pour en remplir d'autres tubes aux innus
mais qu on les remplit patte de façon
plus lente descente en d'accord un petit
peu son temps les beaux mecs vous dit
ouais franchement moi si j'avais des
patrons qui met ces partis en vacances
quand je veux j'en profiterais je ferais
n'importe quoi j'ai besoin d'être cadré
vous l'avez vu pour ses parcours d'essai
donc voilà dont je suis contre ça mais
toutes les entreprises n'ont pas 200
francesca
en tant que saleh le truc c'est que de
toute façon des objectifs vous allez
remplir à partir du moment où vous
faites un travail vous allez remplir vos
objectifs
le petit truc en plus moi qui
m'intéresse c'est que ça évite les burn
out et le band pour chaque société ses
douze mille 600 euros par an et par
salarié
donc même pour eux ils gagneront là
dessus parce que du coup on évite voilà
de se retrouver à un moment donné
submergé on n'en peut plus on n'a pas
assez de vacances profite à tout le
monde ça profite à l'employeur veut
nettoyer sa un contrat de confiance
d'accord et je pense que tous veulent
faire un chef dozo d'ailleurs le oui
était alors venant d'un week-end à
l'autre invité soit déjà parti parce
qu'un article scientifique dans la
harvard business review ce qui explique
que plus le temps de loisirs est
intéressant chez les salariés et plus il
ya de temps de loisirs et plus la
performance au travail est meilleur on
est plus convaincante bien sûr mais bien
sûr alors bien sûr les esprits tordus la
rédac à serge travaille vite je foule
que d'aller puis je me casse tout de
suite il ya des gens qui vont dire mais
c'est super sympa je vais remplir mes
objectifs et je vais prendre du temps de
loisirs et quand vous revenez vous êtes
super en forme regarde comment je suis
regarde commenté
[Applaudissements]